here's my Mount Rushmore all right dude
see don't give me don't give me that
look go ahead let me out it's
it's Jordan yup magic bird and Steph
and I'm about to explain to you I'm
about to explain to you why Steph's
incredible man
Mount Rushmore itself
it's not see the four best hold on let
me just say this before you say this you
see what he did everybody when I said he
was going to do a trick I went to the
guys that I thought were like
accomplished the most did this he's now
he's got a whole now he's got a
definition of what Mount Rushmore really
means
yes yes about Rushmore
is not the four best presidents it's the
four presidents that did the most
important things to have the the growth
of America there it is so when you think
about it like that who are the four
Dudes